[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to believe we're already a
quarter of the way through 2020 and it's
also kind of hard to believe the current
situation we find ourselves in
fortunately there are still plenty of
video games on the horizon so you've got
lots of ways to pass the time this
episode of new releases takes a look at
some of the biggest games of April so
let's dive right in Resident Evil 2
remake rocked the world last year and
now Resident Evil 3 is stepping into the
spotlight our e3 actually overlaps with
- quite a bit as you take control of
Jill Valentine and explore a zombie
filled Raccoon City but this game is
more than just a single-player
reimagining on the original it also
includes the asymmetrical multiplayer
mode Resident Evil resistance 4 players
are survivors while a fifth mastermind
sends all sorts of zombies liqueurs and
even tyrants to take them out that's all
happening on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Friday April 3rd but you can dive into a
demo right now there's another big
remake coming in April final fantasy 7
Square Enix has reimagined cloud stripes
adventure with a whole new combat system
battles are fought in real time but when
the ATB gauge fills you can pause the
action to use items cast magic and
perform special moves I do need to point
out that this remake is only part of the
ff7 story focusing solely on the Midgar
arc but Square says the city is full of
enough content that it'll last you as
long as other mainline Final Fantasy
games it's coming to ps4 on Friday the
10th and like Resident Evil it has a
demo available right now let's go back
to asymmetrical multiplayer with
predator hunting grounds a group of
players must complete objectives on
various maps but one player will become
the predator itself and attempt to kill
them off before they can complete the
mission the soldiers have different guns
in gear and they'll face off against a
scalp hunter or berserker predator which
of course wields alien tech like
camouflage plasma
beam's and more hunting-grounds comes to
ps4 and PC on Friday the 24th and then
we'll all be able to give each other
beefy handshakes [ __ ] that same Friday
RPG fans get their own dose of nostalgia
with trials of mana this is a 3d remake
of the 1995 original the first time it's
been released outside of Japan if you're
not familiar with the game it's an
action RPG where you control three
characters in real-time combat in the
field you choose those three characters
yourself out of a possible six each with
their own story to experience as their
fates weave together you can see them
all on ps4 PC and switch on the 24th
Xbox fans aren't getting left out low
gears tactics is also dropping this
month this tactical title turns the
first person shooter gears formula into
a strategy game with a customizable
squad of cogs taking on the locust it's
not just cannon fodder you'll have to
fight expect some big boss battles two
gears tactics has an original story with
new characters and you can experience it
for yourself on PC on Tuesday the 28th
it is included with game pass for PC but
the Xbox one version has no set release
date yet and those are some of the
hottest games launching all month long
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with a closer look
at more April games next Sunday